here now
in 2020 as covid-19 spread around the
world
a different kind of epidemic was
sweeping Across America anybody know who
did the shooting does anyone see
anything no
no even as other crimes fell murders
spiked by 30 percent
it's the biggest jump in modern history
you had this perfect horrible storm that
resulted in the massive increase in
violence around the country and it
didn't stop there
homicides kept going up in many areas of
America in 2021. I would say he's not
doing great we have an ambulance okay
okay I have never seen so many guns in
the neighborhood
and in 2022 there are no signs the
national murder rate is significantly
falling
so what's behind the huge surge in
violence and what can America do to
avoid this becoming The New Normal
foreign
Chicago's South Side
a few days ago there was a shooting here
retaliation could be on the way
they know that we come in they know why
are we coming
got the whole group out that ain't they
getting everybody rallied up we see guys
standing down on the streets we're going
to engage with them and they know that I
know that they did something
Terence Henderson isn't here to take
sides he's here to stop the Bloodshed
before it escalates
he's an Outreach worker from Chicago
cred one of the city's many violence
Interruption organizations
groups like this attempt to prevent
shootings without relying on police
it's a model that's being implemented
across America
we just know that it's going to be more
shootings that happen if we don't step
in and intervene when a shooting does
take place violence Interrupters race to
the scene to try to calm the situation
down
we had gas in the front we got gas in
the back we watching for cuts and
through the Alleyways and then we always
have a guy that's trailing
um just to make sure that if we have to
get some guys out this area quickly that
is able to happen real fast
I think a little mission is first and
foremost to reduce gun violence and
assess the most at risk to shoot or be
shot individuals in these high crime
areas
it's an urgent Mission although Chicago
has a reputation as a violent Hot Spot
it's actually fairly typical for America
murder rates are above pre-pandemic
levels across the country
the spike in killings has undone almost
three decades of progress in which
homicide rates declined in America
some cities like Philadelphia are now
experiencing murder rates not seen since
the 1990s
even in New York one of America's safest
cities murders Rose by 47 percent the
worry is Rises like this could become
the new Baseline Nationwide
it's kind of like trying to put the
genie back in the bottle once it once it
is out
sociologists call murder rates sticky
once they're up it's hard to bring them
back down
something Outreach workers like Terence
have seen firsthand when it comes down
to the violence in the neighborhoods one
incident will definitely spiral into
multiple incidents and it's going to
always be retaliatory actions
his experience is personal as well as
professional
like many violence Interrupters Terence
was once involved in a criminal
lifestyle
that past helps him step in and defuse
potential violence
the way that we move as Outreach workers
is similar to how we moved when we was
in our criminal lifestyle just without
the crime
[Music]
Terrence spends his time reaching out to
those most at risk of being involved in
gun violence
[Music]
absolutely done a lot of the things that
they've done the best Outreach work has
come from that lifestyle
foreign
peace
I don't want anyone to feel the way that
I felt for years
one of the program's newest participants
is Wesley
I was losing so many people around me at
a young age I lost about five to six
people in my life mostly the gang
violence I've got more involved in the
streets I say
in this kind of environment violence
Interruption organizations are crucial
offering services like life coaching to
help young men control their anger
using these tools help you develop more
Tools in real time on how to get
yourself out of situations
but the spread of covid-19 only made
things harder the local tensions that
Wesley experienced were exacerbated by
the lockdowns
some people weren't surviving during a
pandemic it was hard for them to figure
out what they were going to do how they
were going to eat pay rent through this
so it was like all every man for
theyself
ain't no clubs open ain't no activities
going on outside so you had a lot of
guys that was building in frustration
and a lot of violence definitely
escalated from that
many services including violent
Interruption work had to stop or go
online
often leaving those at risk of being
involved in gun violence with nowhere to
turn
but the murder spike is a problem that
goes far beyond Chicago's South Side
what was quite remarkable was that it
was in cities and towns and suburbs and
rural areas across the country
people of all Races were affected but
due to long-standing inequalities black
communities were the brunt of the
problem
these issues don't just exist in America
many countries have deep-rooted
disparities in their cities
as well as Left Behind rural areas
and much of the world implemented
lockdown
yet almost nowhere else experienced a
sharp spike in its murder rate like
America did
in some countries the rate actually
declined
so what is it about America that could
have contributed to the rise
one factor is guns
America has more of them than any other
country guns even outnumber people
and during the pandemic sales soared
people went to gun stores and and went
to the internet and started ordering and
purchasing guns at about the highest
rate in history
and more guns tends to mean more murders
there's been a number of studies
actually in the last two years that
really prove that the increase in sales
of guns and the availability of guns
directly correspond to the increase in
income violence
guns were used in almost 80 percent of
America's murders in 2020. the highest
percentage since at least 1968.
I've never seen so many guns in the
neighborhood like how I see them today
so it's all kind of different from
military style weapons that's out here
gun carrying in Chicago increased by a
massive 110 percent in 2020. despite the
state of Illinois having some of the
country's strictest firearm laws
cheering a gun is almost second nature
I'll hear what we stay everybody's
carrying a gun in the city but I feel
personally 60 70 of people are carrying
guns for their protection nobody is just
walking around with a gun because it
looks cool the pandemic made people
scared so there's a run on guns
2020 was a scary year for America
and it wasn't just due to the pandemic
on May 25th George Floyd was murdered by
a police officer in Minneapolis
Minnesota
killing Spartan Mass protests across the
country
and the world
it led America to question yet again how
its police officers treat people of
color
and it may also have contributed to the
rise in murders
the thing is it's happened before
last time there was a murder Spike was
in 2015.
that year saw high-profile protests
after police killings of black men
including Michael Brown in Ferguson
Missouri
there is growing outrage tonight after
an unarmed African-American teenager was
shot and killed by police in the St
Louis suburb of Ferguson Missouri
and Freddie gray in Baltimore Maryland
Freddie gray died from a severe injury
to his spinal cord cell phone Billy de
Russia's police dragged him into a van
people have talked about the Ferguson
effect when Mike Brown was killed by
police the increase in distrust in
police and therefore an increase in
violence
after 2015 the murder rate did fall but
it never fully returned to where it had
been
when you have distrust in police you
make it very difficult for police to
solve crimes when you have grieving
mothers in communities who've lost their
young sons and they aren't receiving
what they think is justice
that increases the distrust and what
happens over time is a feeling that we
cannot trust law enforcement and we have
to take justice into our own hands and
so it really increases this retaliatory
cycle of violence and then the distrust
which leads to less cooperation which
leads to less solving of homicides has
its own vicious cycle
[Music]
this is where groups like Chicago cred
come in the violence Interruption model
is expanding across the country as an
alternative to Broken policing
we await to you know law enforcement
finish whatever investigative work that
they do and we just go around those
areas and show support try to find the
victims um and get them some support if
they need it so just to be able to be
that extra added resource to the
community
between 2016 and the start of the
pandemic Chicago had seen a 36 percent
decline in violent crime while it's hard
to measure what exactly causes crime to
rise and fall studies in both Chicago
and elsewhere suggest violence
Interruption can help reduce shootings
but it's an uphill struggle
as soon as Terence gets back to the
office there are reports of more shots
fired
on a possible internet if it didn't
happen the police ain't there do not
make the call to you declined for us to
go through and do a shoe response
they may sometimes beat law enforcement
to the scene of shootings but violence
Interrupters aren't meant to be a
replacement
despite losing a lot of trust the police
will always play a vital role in public
safety
yet to get the murder Spike back down
America may want to reevaluate how it
enforces the law
police departments have to make a real
effort at improving increasing regaining
the trust of the community there must be
an acknowledgment that the trust is
broken the police are supposed to be
able to know their beats walk their
beasts and know stakeholders and be able
to converse with them and get Intel from
them because like that's how I used to
be that's what we're missing right now
change may be needed but the surge in
murders has rattled lawmakers across the
country Law and Order politics are back
this time
reign of
the it is time for it to come to an end
when people are scared there is fear of
violence there is fear of serious crime
uh unfortunately police reform is a much
more difficult discussion when we look
at the data we actually see there is no
need for the battle days of arrest
everybody there is a very small number
of people who are driving gun violence
in any particular City it's less than
one percent we have to focus our efforts
really strictly on the people who are at
the very highest risk of violence and
that's a small number of people
tragically the national murder rate
shows no sign of dropping to
pre-pandemic levels so however America
chooses to tackle it the country
urgently needs to do something before
the spike becomes a plateau
people are just adapted to those
situations
everybody is not monsters
they are not
I'm Daniel Knowles The Economist Midwest
correspondent to read my special report
on violent crime in America click the
link thanks for watching and don't
forget to subscribe